now back in keev Irina Lea has been
displaced a second time by War married
to a Palestinian and with a young
daughter they decided to move to the
relative calm of Gaza when Russia
invaded of course we knew there was
ongoing sporadic conflict with fighting
every couple of years that lasts maybe
up to a month but it was generally
calm when the war broke out on the 7th
of October their neighborhood in Gaza
City was repeatedly hit forcing them to
move to another area further south that
also came under
attack that night we slept in an
underground parking lot well for me that
was normal because When The War Began
here we slept underground for five days
she says their daughter Dasher now four
has become used to the sounds of
War she understood there is a war that
Rockets are flying but she slept well
unlike other children she wasn't
frightened at all along with other
Ukrainian Citizens Arena and her
daughter left Gaza through the Rafa
Crossing with Egypt a husband stay to
look after his
parents every morning literally for half
an hour we have internet and we keep in
touch the most important questions are
whether they have enough food and water
and that they're well thank God
everything is
fine now she's looking to resettle Once
More in keev hopeful for the future
future I have a child we live for the
sake of our children right I hope
everything will be good because all Wars
come to an end one
day but for now both places she calls
home firmly in the grip of grinding
conflict Rob McBride Al jazer
ke make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from Al
jazer